it's decision time in america but who
will win the white house well that all
depends
on who gets to this number 270 that's
the magic number
let me just show you why we'll look at
what happened last time around in terms
of hillary clinton versus donald trump
and have a look at this
hillary clinton got 66 million
votes last time popular vote whereas
donald trump got 63 million he got
fewer popular votes but this was the
crucial thing he won in the right states
he got the most number
of electoral college votes and that's
because he was able to turn around
states like florida like pennsylvania
so let's just ask ourselves what might
happen this time around what does joe
biden have to do to try to get
into the white house we're going to
start with the results from last time
and imagine that joe biden can win back
these states wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania let's turn them blue
and have a look at what's happened to
his count he is in the white house and
potentially that's not the only path
available to him let's turn it back to
where it was before
he could also start to try and focus on
places like florida like
north carolina if he wins those two
states we'll have a look there he's
already
over the line so it shows you there's
two different paths one in the north one
in the south
that joe biden can take and frankly if
he's winning in florida he might well
win
in somewhere like georgia as well how
about for donald trump well clearly
it's a matter of defense if he can hang
on to those states that he won last time
then he's back
in the white house and potentially if he
can start targeting elsewhere places
like new hampshire then he could
increase his lead
but everything is to play for it could
be a really exciting election
and over the course of the evening and
into the following morning
we will bring you all of the data as it
comes out